معي من الدوحه الاهلي لمزيد من المتابعه
مفرد العربيه ليس بازاري ليث اهلا وسهلا
بك جديد مشهد المونديال من عندك وما هي
توقعات الليله سواء مباراه البرازيل او
المباراه يعني المتوقعه ان تكون حاميه بين
غانا والاوروجواي
يوم هناك يعني امبارح كان اللون الاحمر
اللون المنتخب المغربي الذي فاز همم في
المباراه واليوم يتحول الى اصفر واخضر
الكثير من البرازيليين ومشجعين البرازيل
ياتون الى هذه المنطقه للاحتفال او لتشجيع
المنتخب اثناء المباراه ليس من الاستاذ
لوسيل بل من هنا من وسط الدوحه وهذا
المشجع هو ليس برازيليا ابدا يشاهد
مناميحه يبدا اوروبيه وهو من بيل روسيا
همم وين تجي ورائي
متى وصلت وكيف تشجع المنتخب كيف طريقته
كانت تشجيع المنتخب البرازيلي
هو وصل قبل يومين فقط لمشاهده او تشجيع
الفريق البرازيلي في هذه المباراه
واتس الجزيره
نشاهد في عمق الصوره يعني مشجعين فريق
الكرواتي اكيد وهذا يعني شيء جميل هنا
تختلف الصوره كما قلنا قبل قليل كل كل يوم
تختلف بشكل يعني بشكل
بالالوان على الاقل بالوان الناس او
الاشخاص الذين يمرون هنا في سوق مشانب وفي
عمق الصوره يقع سوق واقف الذي يكون مكان
احتفالات عندما يربح اي فريق المونديال
ماتش او مباراه يكون الاحتفالات هناك
مع العلم انه بتعرف حتى بالفوتبول ما في
توقعات يعني يكفي فقط مثال مباريات الامس
همم خصوصا خروج المنتخب الالماني بهذا
الشكل ولكن حتى الساعه ما هي ابرز
التوقعات للمباريات الليله صحيح
مباراه البرازيل الكل يتوقع ان تربح
البرازيل ثلاثه صفر لا ادري لماذا سمعت
كثير ان من الذين مروا هون ان كانوا
برازليين او حتى غير برازيليون قالوا لي
ستكون النتيجه 3-0 لصالح البرازيل ضد
الكاميرون واما بالنسبه للبرتغال يعني
الكل يتوقع ان يربح ان تكون النتيجه اثنين
الى واحد ول يعني حتى هذه اللحظه كما قلت
قبل قليل انت طالب لا نستطيع التوقع باي
شيء يعني شاهدنا فوزي اليابان التي لم تكن
في الحسبان ان تكون ان تفوز في هذه
المباراه ليله امس ايضا والاجواء يعني
مستمره ونحاول ان يكون معكم من امام استاذ
لوسيل الذي ستقام فيه المباراه بين
البرازيل نعم نعم لايف شكرا جزيلا لك لا
نعود اليك في سياق ان نشرات اللاحقه
لمتابعه كل مجريات هذه المباريات بازاري
من الدوحه شكرا جزيلا لك